we're going to stick with politics for a
moment because today is a crucial
primary date especially for democrats
with races in florida and new york that
could have major national implications
kaitlin huey burns is following all of
it for us from washington caitlin good
morning
good morning tony well today is really
all about ron desantis he's not running
against anybody he has no republican
rivals but democrats want to blunt his
rise
desantis has been building a national
profile ahead of a potential 2024
presidential bid and he's amassed a huge
campaign war chest of over 130 million
dollars the governor has really
positioned himself at the center of
republican party issues and culture wars
using his levers of government to enact
policies on education abortion and
election laws and today he's focused on
school board races with about 30
endorsements in those local elections as
education figures to be among the top
issues in this year's midterms now there
are two top democrats fighting today to
take him on that's agriculture
commissioner nikki freed and former
republican governor turned democratic
congressman charlie crist but desantis
is beating them both in the polls you
should also keep an eye on the senate
race in florida where congresswoman val
demings is expected to win her
democratic primary she's the former
police chief of orlando and was part of
the team leading the impeachment
proceedings against trump she's narrowly
leading rubio in the latest polls but
democrats have really been struggling in
florida where former president trump is
popular and desantis is too tony
that's certainly true all right caitlin
thank you very much